when it comes to the internet
there is a massive opportunity right now
to learn a lot of powerful skills
and a lot of strategies for making money
online
building your business creating a side
hustle but unfortunately there's also a
lot of bad advice
and that's true when it comes to youtube
as well and in this video
i'm going to be talking about some
common bad advice that a lot of the
youtube
experts give and i'm going to be honest
i've been guilty of giving this advice
as well but in 2020 right now you can't
afford to follow this advice in my
opinion and it could really hurt you so
stick around and here's why
um i just read this in the new york
times it said how bad is unemployment
i'm streaming and recording this from
las vegas
and um this is coffee with cannell
and how bad is unemployment literally
off the charts
20 million 500 000 jobs were lost
in april here in the us i
uh my business is based here in vegas
and so
around the world we're living through
some absolutely crazy times
so you can't afford to follow bad advice
but hey if we're just meeting uh my name
is sean cannell i wrote a book called
youtube secrets and my passion is
helping you build a
high profit and high impact youtube
channel
um and master really social media and
online business
right now um i've been making a lot of
mistakes over the year i've followed
a lot of bad advice over the years but
recently
i just crossed a million subscribers
over on
think media and uh we've built a
multiple seven
figure business in multiple different
niches with about 40 different revenue
streams so
i'm here to help you uh go further
faster learn from my mistakes
and this show is called coffee with
cannell so if you're just joining what's
up elba
shannon let me know where you're
watching from shout me out what you're
drinking today i'm sipping some
nespresso
um in a think media coffee cup
and uh hit the like button if you're
fired up for today's content
i'm um i think it's one of the most
important topics we could possibly talk
about
and um today's episode is brought to you
by the think marketing podcast we'll
talk about that a little bit more later
um but if let me know if you've started
listening to the podcast yet we recently
launched a podcast that will help you
with the best online business online
marketing and social media skills needed
to thrive
in the new economy and that's everywhere
spotify
google uh youtube but today we're
talking about
common bad advice given by most youtube
experts in fact i'm pretty sure i've
heard every single youtube expert give
this
i've been guilty of giving this as well
and that bad advice
is get ready follow your passion
follow your passion let me know if
you've heard that type that out in the
comments have you ever heard somebody
this isn't just youtube people like oh
you want to be a social media influencer
just follow your passion
like oh you want to make videos just
follow your passion
like oh you want to start a business
just follow your passion now
that can be good at times
but where this really stuck out to me
and why i think we need to uh
talk about this and by the way on coffee
with kennel for like the first 10
minutes we're going to talk about this
topic
and then i'm going to bring you on to
the show and we're going to talk about
uh q a with business and social media
but where this really stuck out to me
was recently i uh
had peter voog a friend of mine on the
video influencers
show let me know if you saw this episode
that happens every saturday on our video
influencers channel
and he um was talking about
uh right now in light of the pandemic
in light of global unrest in light of
unemployment in light of being
on furlough and you know my heart goes
out to you if you've been disrupted
displaced in terms of your job your
business what you thought was secure
um i think that's a sign of the times
what used to be secure is no longer
secure
and in light of all that peter said look
business is business
follow your passion is bad advice
sometimes
you gotta just go make some money come
on
sometimes you actually don't need to
follow your passion
you actually need to follow profit so
we've talked about this before
and this is our framework about how to
pick out your youtube channel and your
niche all right
and so typically we say you know if
you're gonna pick your niche on youtube
it should be what are you passionate
about but what are you all so good at
proficiency
but what is also profitable because if
you go okay i'm passionate about guitar
but i suck at guitar and i can't even
play it very well well then you're
never going to have a successful youtube
channel there and then could you
have guitar lessons over zoom could you
have an online course about guitar yes
there's profit and if you can be in the
intersection of all three that's where
the dream is
but listen right now with what's
happening in the world follow your
passion can be good at
bad advice you got to follow profit and
too many people on youtube and too many
youtube gurus are like
what do you have fun doing like what are
you passionate about
when when your family depends on it you
got to follow the profit man and listen
when you follow the prophet later on you
can find
your passion i think about it like this
i worked at red robin for 10 years what
was one of your first jobs
tell me in the comments you know i
worked at red robin here in the u.s that
is a
burger restaurant i think it's like
american burgers and spirits
is what the tagline was 10 years i
started when i was 17
and up until i was 27 um i
was still picking up shifts on the
weekends to make tips and i did
everything i was the buser
i was the uh what else i was the expo i
was the bird they had a bird mascot
and the clearance between the crotch and
the neck
was not far enough so i kind of had to
hunch my middle body and my whole
manhood was being just crunched
and i remember i went to this church and
i was dancing in our giant red bird
costume
and i don't know if you've ever seen
this before we just got gotta look this
up because this is
this is this is real uh the red robin
bird
um restaurant because there's actually
real red robins apparently on the
internet yeah have you ever seen this
bird before so this is this is where
this is where i worked man red robin
there was me
i've been in this costume before see see
what's happening in the crotch
area right there like that's not a very
big by the way everybody wears this
costume too
and so it stinks in there like the level
of
sweat and human breathing
i don't think for coronavirus this would
be an acceptable
um social distancing like you know you
are not getting fresh air
inside of there but um i worked at red
robin for 10 years i'm gonna tell you
something
i wasn't super passionate about the job
now it is my belief that i made it fun
i had a good attitude that no whatever
you do you do it with all your heart you
do it with gratitude
i believe that you got to be excellent
in the season that you're in and a lot
of times
like your victory in private moments is
what gives you public victory later by
just being faithful growing your skills
but here's why i went to work i'm gonna
tell you why i went to work at red robin
money like i went to work at red robin
to get paid why so i could support my
wife sonya
so that i could pay our mortgage so that
i could buy food
so that i could take care of business
business is business was i
passionate about getting inside of that
red robin costume
i'm the type of person who's gonna stir
up passion for things but no it wasn't
my big dream it wasn't my big passion
i had to just focus on the practical
profit
to pay the bills you know for those that
maybe are familiar with like church
history
the apostle paul 2000 years ago greatest
church planter of all times
really the early spreader of of
christianity because
uh he started to plant churches and
travel
and what a lot of people don't know
about him is you think of him as like
well he's a minister he's a pastor
he's you know he does ministry he's
preaching the gospel
no he had a job and eventually he did
that full-time
but it says in the bible that he made
tense
and so sometimes you even think i got a
passion i got a calling
i want to i want to share my voice for
justice right now and listen i believe
that's super important i want to just
kind of share my opinions and shape
thoughts in the world
great please do that do whatever you
want by the way you know like you can do
whatever you want on social media
i want to i've got a message for the
world great i want to write books
awesome
but what are you doing to fund your
passion and i think it's fascinating to
me
that even when i look at the apostle
paul his passion was the gospel
but yet he focused on profit and said he
made tents all day so he could
share the gospel all night and i think
this looks like the practicality of
when you're building a side hustle you
work a day job while you're chipping
away on your dream job on youtube
but here's why i think that youtube
gurus and youtube experts miss it
is too often they say well start with
your passion no
start with what's going to be profitable
like start with
because listen if you're passionate
about
your topic and you're also good at it
but you can't profit from it
you just have a hobby and that's why i
feel like this is such an important
message right now
in the midst of coronavirus and a
pandemic and unemployment
like you like doing a hobby online and
hoping you make money someday
is not the most practical path to
actually
making serious income and getting
results when it comes to youtube however
i believe actually so i don't think you
actually need the passion p
at the top for even a season
like that profit and proficiency is
enough like if you know about it
it's practical you've researched it you
don't love it i didn't love
red robin wearing this bird suit
sweating my
eyes out having my manhood i'm so
i can't believe we have a son on the way
like after the damage done by this bird
suit
i mean it's a miracle no i
i got good at my job and waited tables
well i danced my heart out in that bird
costume
and and yes you could get bored but
here's why you don't get bored
because if you just have profit and
proficiency you'll be bored if you're
not passionate about it
the reason you you sustain this is
because you got a vision
you got a vision for your family you got
a vision for your future you got a
vision for
what you want to build you got a vision
for feeding your kids you got a vision
for
taking care of your family you got a
vision for giving to your church
you got a vision listen for maybe
passion
projects you want to fund later you ever
heard of a passion project
oh man i just i want to like write a
book i want to do digital photography
i've got some passion projects well
wouldn't it be nice
to have enough profit to fund your
passion project
projects wouldn't it be nice so here's
before we get into q a and i'll share
the link with the team here so we can
dive into uh
bringing you on the show but here's
where this really got super clear for me
and that is that um i was
vlogging for 60 days now i'm not going
to try to talk you out of vlogging but i
might try to talk you out of vlogging
okay
so um i vlogged for 60 days with my wife
sonia
and one of the most powerful things
about
doing that was i learned a lot so it was
on my sean cannell channel
and and probably the good news about
doing it was i was so exhausted
because i had a full-time job and i was
uh working at a church and
all day long and then i'd edit like all
day all night long or whatever
literally for like 60 days in a row so
all of these vlogs
and and they were fun i'm actually
thankful for the history i'm thankful
for the lessons i'm thankful for what i
learned
um but uh here's like the first vlog too
i remember
it was actually my friends benji and
judy they sent me a little elf camera
and i was like i guess i'm vlogging this
is this was the first episode
so this uh is what got me started out
but this is what i learned doing it
so here's here here's a little throwback
what year is this there's my office i
was working at
uh the church lv in las vegas 2012.
um just started vlogging there's our
little gear
closet and uh this was like during a
conference that's pastor benny perez and
i was the director
of communications doing tv and social
media
and so i was vlogging this is on an elf
110 hs what a classic camera you could
probably get one of those for like 60
bucks right now
and so a lot of people want to do this
they're like i just want to do what i'm
passionate about man i just want to
document my life i just want to travel
i just want to travel with my family
hear me vlogger i'm not actually
saying you should not do that but follow
me
um again why it's the dream like
i just want to do what i want to do and
i remember when i heard gary vaynerchuk
tell benji travis the co-author of
youtube secrets he said the reason that
99
of people are failing on youtube and the
biggest mistake they're making
is they're making selfish content
they're making content for themselves
i want to be a famous vlogger i want to
just film my life i just want to like
talk about what i want to talk about and
get paid to do it
well no freaking duh like who doesn't
want to do like this
of course but what if
you thought about the audience first
what
does the audience want in business and
this is why today's brought to you by
the think marketing podcast i hope
you're subscribed
because you got to learn these skills
subscribe to think marketing on apple or
spotify
in business marketing you need to do
market viability is there a market for
your content
is your market even profitable can it
sustain
a certain amount of revenue a business
term you need to know is
pam t-a-m what is the total addressable
market
in your niche the total addressable
market so
what's the total addressable market for
vloggers well theoretically
unlimited but you're trying to sell
entertainment and there's a lot of
competition
whereas there might be a much more
practical path to some other type of
niche on youtube
that could actually fund your dream and
eventually you could do whatever you
want
so after doing this for 60 days this uh
uh vlog um i i had a couple clear
clear moments first of all i think we
had quite a bit of success and what i
mean
is the fact that these were getting like
2 000 views and
uh 4 000 views you know here's a little
morning routine video got 2 400 views
i need to be logged in my youtube
reticance account so we don't
ooh keels that's what sonia makes me use
for my
face wow there's sophie there's our dog
rosie rest in peace
miss her so much and so um here we are
you know like work
vlogging but i saw and i was like okay 2
400 views kyle anderson on the think
media team today
what's up kyle throwback looking
looking 12 years old ultimately
i think he's 14 now um okay so after
vlogging for a while
i started looking at the views i started
looking at
well this isn't actually like how do you
monetize a video like this well
people watching this are not watching
they're not watching like a camera
review
where they're trying to make a buying
decision with their credit card in hand
like which camera should i buy which
could lead to affiliate marketing that's
a practical profit perspective
they're just kind of watching for
entertainment and i saw where i was
and thank god i had a full-time job
because i was so freaking exhausted
after editing
60 days in a row of daily vlogs and i
saw where i wanted to go
financial freedom autonomy i wanted to
write books
your passion wanted to share my message
with more people
my passion i wanted to
but i thought oh man the path i am on
might not be practical
lightly touch the like button if this is
resonating with you
and if you're getting value out of this
video so i pivoted
and this is the clarity i got and this
is why it's great to just post like
videos
because it's by posting that you get
clarity i believe sometimes
that's just by putting out a lot of
videos you learn more about yourself you
learn more about
what works what doesn't work but i was
learning like wow
i actually don't know if there's a
practical
like my friend peter said business is
business follow your passion is bad
advice during a pandemic you need to
follow
profit you need to follow solving a
problem
entrepreneurs are simply people that
solve problems for profit
and there's a lot of problems in the
world to solve right now you might solve
problems
helping people get in shape helping
people get their personal finances in
order
helping people with stock investing with
saving helping people
with health products with skin care with
makeup
a specific passion ironically
even my friends benji and judy who have
been vlogging for over 10 years now
and have she they have over now a
billion views on their main
vlog channel judy started with a
practical youtube channel
beauty tutorials hair tutorials
practical how do you profit brand deals
affiliate marketing youtube ads
you've actually figured out a business
plan look if you want help with this
and this is resonating with you and
you're recognizing wow that is bad
advice that i've heard before like just
follow your passion
and and listen listen if you want to
just have a hobby and get on youtube
go for it but one of our passions here
at think media is to help 10 000 people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with online video
so we want to help 10 000 people go full
time so i'm obsessed with your success
but if i'm going to get you to full time
i got to tell you that following your
passion sometimes can be bad advice
what you need to do to get full time is
figure out
how to go full time figure out how to
get your money right
figure out maybe a vehicle what's your
vehicle to profit
so maybe you join and do direct selling
and people hate on it but like direct
selling
can be awesome of course there's bad
companies but usa you get into essential
oils
you get into unique makeup direct
selling right you get into
doterra essential oils or young living
or something
and you get into a product that you love
and you build up a youtube channel
listen
that maybe is around lifestyle and day
in the life and a lot of fun things but
now you've got a vehicle
to to actually make money because not
only can you sell
products but you can sign people up on
your team
that's just one way like in our advanced
trainings we talk about 51 different
ways to make money with youtube but you
got to get your money right man
you got to get your profit right man and
like sometimes people are like oh
dude sean talks about money too much
well you don't talk about money enough
oh like that's like greedy like the you
know the love of money
uh like no the love of money is bad but
money is good money is a tool
to solve problems
last time i checked you can't take
subscribers to your mortgage
person and say here here's how many
subscribers i have you can't even take
youtube views and say hey i got some
youtube views you can't take instagram
likes
you can't take facebook likes to your
insurance company and say hey could i
just give you some of my facebook likes
this month
now you need money man take care of your
kids take care of your family
so let me know if you got value and let
me know if you have any questions
uh we're uh getting into uh
the s link today
and uh melissa and elena i don't know if
y'all are on here i dropped the link
inside of um a slack please share it
and uh we're gonna get into some of your
um bring you on the show today for
coffee with kennel but let's summarize
the bad advice
that a lot of youtube experts give and a
lot of social media experts give is
follow your passion
and follow your passion take it back to
2019
better advice because in 2019
there wasn't a pandemic man people made
there's more money in the system
but when people are getting laid off and
people are being furloughed and people
are uh um
you know not able to
pay their bills you got to be real
practical about how you're going to
generate
income about how you're going to
generate money
and so uh this is coffee with cannell
hit like if you're
if you got value out of today and um and
think about let me know what niche
you're in and let me know let me know
let me know this what is your best way
of earning money how do you plan on
earning money with your youtube channel
is your youtube channel a does it have
what's the profit potential of your
youtube channel and if you don't know
the answers to some of these questions i
want to recommend the think marketing
podcast
let me know if you've been on this if
you've uh
subscribed to this before or heard about
this before we just talked about
affiliate markets a way to make money
you're going to learn strategies
talked about how to build your email
list and some of the skills you need to
be
mastering right now are
marketing our sales are our business
sean i just want to talk about like
i just want to be creative and just like
share you know my ideas
cool but when it's like
mission critical time and when the
world's melting
you got to go beyond just what you wanna
do
and sometimes you gotta put on a red
bird suit
and you gotta you know uh actually
uh generate some income and so uh
man coffee with kennel hit the like
button uh check out the think marketing
podcast
if you're watching this on youtube we
also have a video podcast so you can
subscribe on youtube
make sure you're subscribed or go over
to youtube and there's a think marketing
youtube channel with all kinds of bonus
content
we have channa today uh techno dad
who is crushing it by the way tana break
it down tell people what you do
uh you've been a part of our community
for a long time but man you're killing
it with the
with the profit man you you figured out
a practical way to profit
you got multiple streams of income what
is it you're doing to make all this
stuff happen
um thinking outside the box
um tomorrow in fact we are
me and my friends are putting on the
very first
online hi-fi trade show it's a five-day
trade show
and we've sold 400 tickets and out of
our goal was to have 50 exhibitors we
got 47
and um yeah man it's it's gonna be nuts
so
uh the youtube channel is doing great
it's making anywhere from two thousand
to four thousand a month
um we close like 20k
in sponsorships in january and february
um and that that split up between three
people
so you know uh strategy was to
group together band together um
so with the couple other guys that do
the same
ish kind of stuff you know home audio
home theater stuff
and um it's been great man
yeah i get to talk to them all the time
you know my wife
doesn't get sick of me sick and tired of
me talking about youtube
you know um i could talk to these guys
about it and uh
we're making money we're having fun and
we're just
we're growing uh remember uh we
what was it ces this year uh ran into
you right that's right ran into you in
the hall
you were like hustling too you were like
talking to brands and then like taking
gear back to the room to like produce
and shoot brand deals like on the spot
yeah so things actually changed so
previous uh ces i made 21 videos
right in that week this ces i made one
video
and the rest of the time it was closing
deals with the decision makers of these
big brands like klipsch
like len brook who owns um dolly
speakers nad we're talking high
end stuff like high high priced items
um and you know they're all part of our
show they've been on our weekly
we do a weekly podcast we started
another channel
that's based around our company called
daily hi-fi and every monday
we do like an hour to an hour and a half
and we've got
industry bigwigs industry giants
coming in and talking to us about hey
yeah
sometimes they're pushing their new
product but um
this last one uh this week we had um
this uh one guy from aix records and he
was
talking about how the difference between
high resolution and low resolution audio
the average person just cannot tell the
difference
and he went through this big study you
know he was uh
working at a college and he was doing
this experiment and you can actually go
and download all the files and
and be part of the experiment it's still
ongoing right now and um
it's great man we are actually like
becoming a foothold or creating a
foothold in this industry and we're
changing it it's crazy
yeah it's inspiring man you're doing so
much cool stuff there was a lot of
nuggets and everything you were
dropping and and how long you been at
this now like when you add it all up
because this you didn't just
do this overnight like you've been
building uh i started the youtube
channel 2016
and in august and then i joined video
ranking academy your course
um following year and um
yeah oh last year oh you know what i
watched the video
uh the interview that you and i did um
at ces
2019 i had 36 000 subscribers then i'm
just at about 73 000 now and i actually
slowed down
on my output because it's more about
um behind the scenes kind of stuff as
opposed to just
pumping out videos i can pump out videos
like nobody's business right
um i remember when i got vra i was doing
a daily vlog
and you and benji told me to stop right
i actually
you guys had that call and you know i
was the second channel and they're like
your home theater videos are doing
really well i would stop doing the vlogs
and um and uh when i was doing those
daily vlogs
i was doing daily vlog and three tech
videos a week so 10 videos a week
is what i was pumping out it was
ridiculous so
um so yeah um i don't need to do that
anymore
i'm one video a week two videos a week
i got a ton of product to get through
here and
um we're just working on more back end
stuff this trade show thing is huge
for us uh so um
yeah man it's it's it's super exciting
i'm
totally stoked and i had no idea oh oh
oh covet if it were not for youtube
and the money that we were making from
youtube those first two months
um before my wife's unemployment came in
we would have not been eating anything
wow so like all because i dj weddings
so what happened there they shut down
yeah
nothing nothing's going on and i don't
think i'm gonna be djing a wedding
until late august early september
so all that money is just not happening
um
so i i'm super fortunate that i started
the youtube channel when i did
you know otherwise we would like those
first two months would have been rough
rough man inspiring by your journey and
listen everybody that's some powerful
stuff you know youtube is not an
overnight thing
shauna started back in 2016 uh but he
was smart because he got strategy and he
invested and he learned
and we may have just lost him always
back and uh he uh and he positioned
himself for the future that's what we
got to be doing right now
we got to be looking ahead even though
times are hard right now we got to be
thinking about positioning ourselves
for multiple streams of income for uh in
the right niche in a profitable
niche i love it but hey is there
anything i can help you with you got a
question about anything you just wanted
a vibe today
oh um i can't hear you i don't know
what's happened
i got a phone call and i can't hear
anything anymore um
but i i've been awake for 26 hours so
um how about we just say goodbye for now
because i can't hear anything
take it easy sean good time appreciate
you what a session man love tech no dad
and uh
man business is business closed 20 000
deals
collabed with a couple of different
people 20 000 dollars in brand deals
partnered up that was some insight i
love china because he's thinking about
business development he's thinking about
his profit
this is coffee with kennel if you're
just joining the replay you can check
we talked all about the bad advice at
the beginning and today's brought to you
by the think marketing podcast
if you haven't subscribed to the think
marketing podcast
whether on youtube whether on uh
you know apple google that's where we're
going to help you build your business
man we help business-minded content
creators and you might not be
business-minded yet
you're going to learn sales you're going
to learn marketing you're going to learn
social media
it's like the iceberg youtube is like
the tip of the iceberg
but man underneath it is like
communication
copywriting sales business online
marketing
strategy positioning all these other
skills
uh productivity right all that stuff
underneath and so
we talk about that on the think
marketing podcast but
this is coffee with kannel where we
bring you on and answer your questions
uh tana did i say your name right how's
it going
it's tawana i'm doing well thank you uh
wanna thanks so much for being on
uh where are you coming from that that
suv looks
fire like what a moon roof hi that's
awesome
where are you streaming from what do you
do i'm in newark new jersey
okay and i am a local pastor here
for the last uh 11 12 years and um
as you know the pandemic has been you
know what it has been so we've been
doing a lot of zooming
and um things of that nature we have a
small ministry
but a powerful ministry i'm very excited
about that
that's amazing so you guys are doing
zoom meetings are you doing any kind of
other live streaming or that is the live
stream
that we're just doing zoom i have kind
of kept it kind of
intimate and personal with my church um
only because there's been so much going
on
um on uh you know live stream and things
of that nature so
uh my church we just kind of felt real
more comfortable with
uh keeping it simple and intimate and
then they're able to invite people that
they would like to invite but we're
definitely not doing any live stream
right now
i love it tawana well hey what can i
help you with today
well i have uh i have thoroughly let me
say i have thoroughly enjoyed
think media and and vr i've joined vra
i'm super excited about it all uh but
there's so much
um i have gotten just about everything
that you guys have told me i'm in my car
now
i have my m50 with me let's go adobe
and all of all of the things that you
guys have recommended
um i have reset my studio at home um my
office into a studio to
my soft light boxes and and
tripods and i mean literally everything
uh today
i got my uh my samsung turret one
terabyte
drive everything i mean i probably i
went crazy i happen to be a techie by
by nature absolutely like love
technology just like me
yeah i absolutely love it now personally
and this is this is my thing personally
i'm looking to build my youtube channel
i started some years ago
um doing some youtube um and i stopped
once my son moved away because he was
doing all of the editing which i knew
nothing about
um and so we kind of let the the uh
the channel go by the wayside um but i
am super
ready to get back into it um and i have
been
the person that you all speak of that
let technology get in the way
um where i figured i needed all of this
to get started instead of just pressing
record
i'm her um you do that again my picture
should come up literally
um and so so now i'm ready to get
started and
i i was listening to you talk and now as
much as it's my passion
i'm not quite sure how to make it
profitable
what's your channel about is it ministry
biblical topics things like that or what
it was yes it was definitely biblical
topics it was more
kind of leaning towards leadership
motivate motivation and things of that
nature from a
um from a faith-based perspective
um and so i am still very much
interested in doing that
um but i think i want i'm just not quite
sure
which direction i need to go in order to
make that profitable
um yeah yeah you know i think i do
better with live than i do with
kind of record and edit i think
but again it's my thought not
necessarily
the best thing yeah i love it well um
so grateful for you and i can relate
when i started to uh
really lean into youtube sometimes even
investing in gear which you got all the
best stuff and you have it and you're
set up
but it can sometimes be a way that we
procrastinate from
pressing record and i used to do that
i'd be like i don't have the right lens
i need to get another lens until i shoot
another video
because i was generally just you know
trying to get over that
hurdle of fear of am i going to be
judged fear of other people's opinions
how's this going to go am i going to
look stupid on camera and so you really
do just got to press record and start
shooting videos
you know i think what you need to ask is
you do need to ask
how soon does your youtube channel need
to be profitable if you will
like um because sometimes the fastest
path to profit it may be
whatever you already have set up through
being
on staff at your own ministry and giving
in your non-profit it may be
some other thing that you're part of or
it may be your youtube channel if it
needs to be a real profitable youtube
channel
it's almost like you could pick about
going into
uh like a direct selling company that
does clothing or like a direct selling
company that does
uh you know makeup or skincare or
something and then
leverage your youtube channel and this
is actually not my advice for you but i
want everybody to hear this just for
coffee with canel
um like for example unique is a um
is a direct selling company that does
makeup stuff right so i think i looked
up unique may
beauty box so they sent out a box every
month and so
this channel for example this video got
seven views
70 views 86 views so she just pressed
record
the video is vertical nothing fancy
she's talking clearly about the may
beauty box
and she says check out the the deets now
she's missed a ton of opportunities here
only has one subscriber so think about
this she's got
86 more views than her subscribers
and is like barely starting this
you know like but nevertheless getting
these different
uh getting results
because people are searching for the
beauty box in may 2020. now
in her description she should have um
a link to buy the box and the product
from her which she would earn money from
probably more than affiliate marketing
and then also two that you could join
her team as a distributor
so all i'm saying is that would be a
practical way to profit and there's
different
um uh direct selling companies to
look at this person 1500 views
her unique presenter kit she's breaking
it all down that's
more views than her subscribers so
everybody's out here trying to just talk
about
a passion or something she's going
directly to
her uh to something that's profitable
because really when you have
direct selling you have a business in a
box again
not actually saying that this is what
you have to look at this one
so this one starts on camera here
and then the camera like flips there's
like almost there's no editing
and there's just opening the box and
like unboxing what's in the box
7084 views okay
channel has 123 subscribers and in the
description
this is the way to do it want to see
more products click here
links over to unique and now she's able
to make money and again
i'm assuming this is actually around her
passion for beauty
and for makeup etc so that's one example
of how i think about choosing a more
profitable and practical niche
now in your case though i do think
there's something about
stacking and synergizing your ministry
your meeting
as a group on zoom and you're starting a
youtube channel
and this is a longer path
but i would say you know a pastor
is technically a thought leader and
the thought leader industry the
influencer industry i don't mean like
the instagram influencer industry i mean
like the author
speaker um kind of
industry blogger podcaster
the way you make money in that industry
is through selling knowledge through
selling information
an author is selling information right
and
a and today i have my i have a i have a
book perfect
yeah have you done an audio book yeah
did you do an audio book i've always
wanted to
is your book on amazon
it is yes what's the book called
it's called the wine press the making of
a quality leader
so uh what i would do you do so think
about this you have something to sell so
every single video you make
can tie back
to something to sell that's like the
practical thing to think about
as a thought leader as a as a content
creator and so
maybe you can send me it might be kind
of hard because i think you're on your
phone but
i'm wondering is it under your name
tawanna thompson uh
the wine press is winepress two words
uh it's one word the wine press okay the
wine press the making of a quality
leader
um yes let's see here
and it's tawana t here we go here we go
all right this is it right here right
right that's it
great great yes so similar to you i
wrote a book years ago called
youtube for churches and so you know
that if you sell a kindle you get seven
bucks right
seventy percent and
yeah yeah and so um there's something
about
i would on youtube create videos
answering specific questions about
leadership
i would actually probably better because
that might be hard to break out
in i would join in your case i'd be
talking
about and i'd go into your members area
in the youtube hyper growth blueprint
and i would look at influence surfing
and trend surfing and i'd be talking
about the topics of the day from a
leadership perspective i'd be talking
about a lot of the
very important topics right now
regarding black lives
justice uh regarding um
the united states the world how can we
lead now how can we navigate right now
how can we raise our voice for justice
how can we have grace and empathy
from whatever from your perspective and
then referencing your book so you think
about as as a
content creator thought leader like you
you create free content
and then you say hey and and by the way
i talk about this more in my book link
in the description below
and as that scales up you start just
doing the math this is like the
practicality of it you start thinking
okay if i make seven dollars off a ten
dollar e-book
because you get 70 on the amazon
affiliate
or or you know kindle epub
whatever the back end's called if you
sold 10 books a day
you're going to make 70 dollars a day
700 get no no no so if you do seven
times 10 you're going to make 70
a day and that then becomes a foundation
now that's that that takes a while like
you don't just upload a video get 100
views and sell 10 books every single day
but now you've got to hear you at all i
love cardio
uh i think can everybody else hear me
you may have lost me but i wonder if the
same thing happened to china
if you can't hear me just it just
completely went out i don't know what
happened
it might have went on like bluetooth or
something it might have went
uh somewhere else so we may
need to say goodbye but i'll still give
you a couple tips and we'll play the
replay
for you i can't hear you at all you just
went completely out
can everybody else hear me i want to
make sure okay great
and so um we uh
i'll keep giving you some tips so you
have the replay uh tawanna
but uh i think that's the final
conclusion we really had two big
strategies and if you've been getting
value out of today's coffee with cannell
hit the like button
and then um and drop a comment of what
your aha moment has been
so far so again look at that unique
strategy
sign up for unique become a direct
seller by the way
if you were going to do that and am i
saying you should become a direct seller
not necessarily
i'm saying that's a vehicle to profit
that becomes real practical during a
pandemic
guess what didn't go down during the
great depression makeup and beauty
you know what else didn't go down during
the great depression entertainment
because people still needed to escape
still needed entertainment
and because especially ladies still
wanted to look good
come on even during the great depression
it was like i might be buying cheaper
makeup but i'm still buying makeup
so uh you got to be practical
on your profit and you we saw you see
how practical that was
you're making videos about whatever
meanwhile the
may unique unboxing is getting
7 000 views building your team building
your money
but if you're a thought leader let me
know if that's if you'd consider
yourself a thought leader you want to be
in the thought leader industry
meaning your podcaster content creator
you want to be an author you want to
speak on stages you maybe want to make
an online course
you got to figure out how to make money
and the key is to to develop something
to sell
the final thing i'd tell you tawanda is
to turn it into an audiobook
because this is going to blow your mind
y'all i would recommend if you want to
get the audio book for youtube secrets
go to tubesecretsaudio.com
and you can get it for free but let me
explain
how that works so if you go to tube
secrets audio which all we did was
uh buy a url from godaddy and redirect
it
okay it redirects right here so free
with a 30-day trial
tubesecretsaudio.com if somebody can do
me a favor wherever you're watching this
could you type that in the description
for people www.tubesecretsaudio.com
you get the book free and literally it's
free so you sign up for a trial even if
you cancel
you get to keep the book okay and
if you stick with it like i love audible
right i joined free
at one point and then i stick with it i
listen to all kinds of audiobooks
but tawanna i want you to uh
to make an audio book and this is a
great strategy because guess what
happens
when people sign up for a free audible
trial you get paid
five dollars that's right even if they
cancel
like amazon pays you five dollars if
they sign up for a gold membership
you get ten dollars and if they buy an
audio book and they already have audible
you only get 50 cents so thanks for
supporting the book if you if you
already have audible and you buy the
book
appreciate it you know 50 and i'm truly
grateful but we have made
a lot of money like a lot of money
from giving our audiobook away free
come on drop a little explosion emoji
throw down a little bit of
lightning bolt i don't know get the bag
emoji like giving away a free audio book
so you teach free content on youtube and
say hey you want to go deeper on this
and take this on the road with you grab
my whole audiobook you teach leadership
faith business
i know we're going deep on this but i
think that you're probably getting some
some value out of that is
is do an audio book and what you can do
then
is what we'll do is at the beginning of
a video we created a little ad spot 15
seconds and it's like
want to get a copy of youtube secrets
free go to tube secrets audio it's like
heather's voice over on the think media
team
and and we just will interview other
people promote the audiobook
do a podcast promote the audiobook add
some value promote the audiobook
powerful and we've made tens of
thousands of dollars now and mind you
we're at scale we got big numbers
um but here's the deal
um just off the audiobook we've made
over 30
000 to be exactly specific does that
seem crazy
that's real and
am i saying that that's those results
are typical
no i'm am i saying though that you could
earn an extra 300
a month from implementing these
strategies and doing them really
intentionally right now
yes am i saying that this can be really
practical
yes am i saying that it starts with
selling one or giving away one audiobook
free a month
and then it's one a week and then it's
one a day
and then it's five a day and then five a
day is 50 bucks a day
and then it's evergreen and the money's
coming in and by the way that's just one
income stream
that is just one stream you can imagine
audiobooks physical books ebooks youtube
ads affiliate marketing
and so tawana that's what i'd say uh i
would actually lean into
ministry topics i talk about trending
topics from that sharp
prophetic biblical perspective i'd
on the say of the day i would answer
specific questions about faith about
leadership
and so a lot of that shoes in your
members area and by the way you have
access to vra foundations we just
completely updated vra
so i would recommend um going into the
facebook group and make sure you've
accessed the most recent training
because that's my best advice for you
it's all laid out
and the brand new update we just rolled
out to the video ranking academy i think
we have time
for uh one more but i want to remind you
uh today's coffee with kennel is brought
to you by
think marketing we launched a brand new
youtube channel why because we realize
more than tech and cameras
um you gotta know about this kind of
stuff
like i think we had an unlock with the
fact of how we can make money from
audiobooks
you may not want or think you need to
build an email list
this is what we learned this is not a
sexy topic this is not a
hot topic or whatever right this is a
how to build an email list fast
is a topic that you need though it's
like sometimes you do the stuff you want
i want to create go live cool
but then you also got to learn the
skills you need to succeed
right and so think marketing is
on youtube make sure you subscribe over
there and we have a weekly podcast that
comes out every tuesday it's on apple
itunes
it's on spotify it's on google it's on
everywhere podcasts
listen to let me know a question for you
do you listen to podcasts and b
um where do you listen to podcasts tell
me in the comments
and uh definitely subscribe to think
marketing where we'll help you with
all of these skills brick by brick well
we got dawn
um on the coffee with kennel our nomadic
story don good to see you how you doing
today tell people
where you're streaming from and what it
is you do
yeah so i'm streaming from my rv
and um i'm in pensacola and and what i
do is
uh professionally i'm in the it services
business but i'm now starting my
business and uh
using video to support that and our
focus is
on being able to support people uh to
live the life they imagine
and we want to do that in a nomadic
backdrop yeah because you're living the
life you imagine by being able to travel
being able to uh to live life on your
own terms right
yeah and with covid right now we're at
our home base which we refer to as
hashtag
nano rv park because it's basically a
one site rv park
and this is the original travel trailer
we have so i'm in the travel show
because my wife is
kind of happy that i work not inside the
rv
but um i'm focused on you know growing
my
my my business and my question to you
really is
i'm focusing for 50 videos by the end of
the year so that means basically two
videos
a week i've just this week is the first
week i've gotten through two since i've
built my foundation
i'm mostly focused on building up a
portfolio
of of of videos that will support my
profit so two-thirds of my videos will
be something with
products or that have products
associated with it right now i'm in a
series going over the berkey water
filter
i have an affiliate program that i'm a
part of so i'm i'm lining those up
and um what i did was i i started with
um taking this from grow with video live
started and i've mapped out over 50
videos
and and of those 16 of them are
my first 16 shows from my podcast
starting next week
so my question to you is does it make
sense i'm not focusing on building
influence
per se that's not my main focus i want
to build a portfolio of 50 videos
so that i can then as i'm building
influence people can land and start
going around my videos and using them
and if i make some profit along the way
which i don't have to right now because
i'm i have a good paying job that sets
me up foundation
and within three to five years i want to
be able to
decide if i can do this full time and
leave leave corporate america
yeah i love it well you know it's nice
to have the ability
to you've got the job so you don't need
to necessarily monetize immediately um
and i think those listening to this
episode should consider that because if
you are able to fund your passion if you
will well then it gives you different
options and different
different choices i do want to address a
couple mindsets don and i would say
i wouldn't hesitate or shrug away from
saying i don't want to build my
influence
of course you want to build your
influence you actually want to lean in
and say
uh i absolutely want to build my
influence i
passionately want to build my influence
i aggressively want to build my
influence and why
i think sometimes we might hedge and say
you know uh
maybe i don't want to be selfish or i
don't want to be self-absorbed i don't
want to have a negative aspect of
selfish ambition
but when you figured out not only have
to have this great i.t
job and you figured out not only to live
this
awesome nomadic lifestyle and you're
sharing great value
and you're a man of integrity and family
and impact i want to encourage you that
we need your influence more than a lot
of the people that are influencing right
now
like you don't need just 64 subscribers
you need 640
000 subscribers because there's a lot of
people with 640 000 subscribers in my
opinion that shouldn't have a lot of
influence
because they're not uh helping people
with the values
and and just the helpful kind of content
that people need in the world so i think
that i get it sometimes
like oh you know should i put myself out
there like is it arrogant or is it is it
prideful or is it
well no when you've got a good heart and
you want to make a difference in
people's lives
you should want a billion subscribers
because if you're being good to people
helping them with stuff
being ethical then why wouldn't you want
to help as many people as possible so if
that's the case
then you actually want to ask yourself
the question how can i reach more people
and how can i build my influence in the
most effective way that's thing one
thing two i want to address
is the punting of the of of the dream of
maybe doing this full-time down the road
multiple years
it may take that long and thank god that
you've got the infrastructure
to with the i.t job for it to take that
long that is i think
the practicality all of us should have
if i had to wait
wait tables at red robin for 15 years or
20 years
um which was where i was you know
serving burgers and being a waiter
uh every single week then great
if i can go full time on youtube at your
tenant at red robin or year 15 or year
22 it's the dream no matter what so i'm
committed
to doing whatever it takes but i do
believe there's a shorter path and a
more practical path and so as we get
into that
what i would say is definitely
upload at least a video a week and
definitely do what
you're doing you may have already said
this but i hope you've unpacked vra
foundations a little bit but we go so
deep into
answering specific questions and these
are the types of videos
that are so great because they're
practically helping people
that want to solve specific problems and
i got to share this with you
we have a new family member in the think
media team called big blue this is
heather's
it's just this past weekend heather
taurus uh just added big blue
to the family and uh so
heather just kind of became like even
your target audience like
how do i install a fluoride filter like
how do i
uh prime the filter and
you know fresh water versus the potable
water and there's there's so many
practical ways what's cool about your
channel is two things i believe that
it's perfectly positioned
for both influence and for income
because it solves a particular prop uh
problem
and to encourage everybody watching that
caught the whole stream
don is in a position of having a gift
because he is passionate about this
but it's also profitable and there's
also proficiency there's people that are
looking for alternative forms of living
that are like shoot
times are so hard uh i might want to
actually
just kind of move into a lower cost more
affordable
so what i guess what i would encourage
you john uh don is
uh is it's all there in vra foundations
but specifically what i would do if i
was you is i would answer
as many specific questions as i could
and
i would answer them in a couple
different categories
one yes practical rv travel related
um like how to fix this and do this
i would another category would be
location based things
uh navigation based things like best
path
sites to 10 sites you should see 10
10 best like you have so many
opportunities
and this might sound crazy but like what
i'd be thinking is how do you get to
your first 1000 videos
how do you get to your first a thousand
videos 10
must-see places in the u.s um and then
five tips for reducing expenses
three ways to and just and just going
crazy but really following the vra
system that you're already a part of
and so any thoughts on that or any
feedback question on any of the stuff we
talked about there
yeah so i probably miscommunicated just
a little bit
what i'm what i'm doing is i'm focusing
on all the the foundational things like
the the
answering the questions and products and
you know the top five things you need to
worry about
you know as you start out on the road or
whatever what i was saying is i wasn't
tailoring my content
to only build influence i plan to build
influence through the content i have
my show is going to be more of the
platform that's a little more you know
out there to share
more of my thoughts and and and those
type things and then when we get back on
the road after all this covet is
then you'll start seeing pretty places
and things they'll draw you in but the
real thing i want to be able to do is
through all this not to say hey this is
a cool place go look at it is to say
if you live intentionally you can change
your life and
and nothing that you dream about or
imagine is
non-attainable you can attain it anyways
so example
heather you mentioned spent 18 years
dreaming this dream
and she's now there and she's now living
it and and she
is and i would love right now i'm
inspired to want her to be
part of my audience because i can help
so much so
as soon as i saw that i started spinning
the wheel saying what content can i
focus on
to help get ahead of where they're at
which is behind me which is exactly what
you teach in your training is
you know look at yourself from three or
five years ago focus on that and those
are the people you want to make as your
audience
so i really appreciate this time with
you sean absolutely
and so my question then and and uh i'm
glad we were synced up on that and that
sounds amazing you got your strategy
locked and loaded when is the show start
the show's gonna start next week i've
already got it all prepped
video podcast yeah it'll be a video
podcast that i'm gonna go through libsyn
and then distribute nice and so yeah
that that's a great strategy
and what i love about that for those
listening too don's really doing it
right
is that's a good intimacy piece it's a
good connection piece like you said it's
the lifestyle the mindset
i love your confidence and your energy
uh and and the practical there's the
practical videos answer specific
questions but then the invitation to
listen to yours it going to be a weekly
show is that what you said
yep and my first video first episode is
gonna be named
just press record here we go man you
gotta just press record well don
appreciate you so much and thanks so
much for coming on i'm so excited
look i i literally cannot wait first of
all for when you roll through vegas and
we do a meet up with heather and uh
and uh the team out here and also your
channel is gonna really crush
it's a matter of just posting the video
staying consistent and you know
that it takes 35 to 55 videos just to
kind of get things going
um but uh inspired by everything you're
doing and could it be better timing for
exactly
when you find someone like a heather
i'll say when we found heather on alt
our team as you know she became the
perfect person wanting to learn video
now she's like wanting to learn rv
wanting to learn video and like
oh we were like wow we're so out of
touch we know so much we've studied so
much
i've been doing video for 15 years and
heather was like sean
slow down talk more simply actually help
me
you know like our 4s strategy the
questions we answered should be
stupid specific simple starter questions
because the curse of knowledge holds us
back so i'm so great that
you have kind of that if you will an
avatar or
and of course a friend as well uh to
think about all the pain points that
she'll be going through
and uh man i'm excited for the journey
together uh
that we're on thank you very much sean
all right take care don
hey coffee with kennel the weekly q
a show to help you with your questions
related to business social media online
marketing
youtube and life and if you got value
hit the like button on today's show
brought to you by the think marketing
podcast i saw some people
that uh like to just listen to audio
podcasts only some video podcasts only
um and i know that uh a couple people
shared a few different plat
platforms like repond let me know where
you listen to podcasts and if you
haven't started people listen to google
play
um if you haven't started listening to a
podcast a great one to start with
and to subscribe to is the think
marketing podcast
um every single week every tuesday in
fact we drop a new episode
to help you grow and scale your business
with online video and the latest money
making strategies
for making money online
as well as helping you maximize online
video and social media across
uh all the different channels the reason
we started a new youtube channel was
because
think media is going much more into the
best cameras and microphones
and all those types of things that you
need the tools really
and the tech that you need for building
your influence
with video and so our newest channel
called think marketing which is where we
post the video podcast
version is a new youtube channel as well
so subscribe if you're not subscribed
and if you got value out of today and
you think this kind of conversation
and this kind of content would be
helpful it the way
this is you know of course all free um a
way that
you could share that gratitude is just
share it with somebody that it could
help
we really believe that uh we need to
think different during this time pivot
during this time
adjust during this time there's a lot of
disruption going during this time and
it's easy to focus on what's going bad
um but hidden in every obstacle is
hidden opportunity
and entrepreneurs solve problems for a
profit
and the world's got problems right now
can i get an amen we got some problems
your your spouse has got some problems
right now can i get an amen no no no
don't no
you you could you could still type that
because it's true come on we all got
problems
we all got issues and uh that's the
power of entrepreneurship
of content creators help people sleep
help people deal with anxiety and
burnout
help people live a lifestyle of freedom
if they want to potentially live on the
road
and do something like our nomadic
lifestyle help people
um solve problems in all types of
different areas help people with online
video with social media
you know don't even worry about if
you're like well sean you're already
doing it i feel like i could help with
social media and digital marketing are
you kidding
everybody needs to learn these skills
right now the most in-demand skills
um heather just posts i might be able to
look it up she was sharing it with our
team
and it was a noah keegan post talking
about
industries that are going up right now
listen to this um five professions that
are on the rise
in 2020 based on google search tick tock
editor
up 733 online dog trainer
up 180 instagram marketer up 155
squarespace designer that's a web
designer but specifically helping people
get their squarespace website set up
129 podcast editor
up 91 and there's a carousel here
so you can see the different google
trends and whatnot
it's time to pivot there are yeah
there's a lot of hardship a lot of
things going down but there's a lot of
things going
up so you want to position yourself for
the new economy for the wave
and that's what the think marketing
podcast coffee with channel and think
media is committed to
we're helping you learn online video
live streaming and social media so let's
stay connected
if we um aren't connected on instagram i
would love to
vibe with you over there at sean cannell
on
instagram sean cannell rhymes with
youtube channel and
i post a lot of uh instagram tv
content to just kind of keep you with
tactical things like best export
settings for youtube videos
that's going to be in the feed there so
you could you know turn on notifications
or whatever
and uh as well as daily instagram
stories and whatnot to
help keep you inspired or give you some
practical
uh content so all of that is happening
on instagram
at sean cannell this is our weekly show
coffee with kennel and i want to thank
you for being here episode 10.
guess what this show started because of
the lockdown
this show started because we were
pivoting ourselves
i don't even have a show i was scared i
didn't even want to go live with stream
yard in 720p because i'm a tech nerd
and i thought 27p was beneath me but
some of you didn't even notice
and some of you are super offended like
i am but guess what done is better than
perfect
grab a usb mic put in a light grab a
webcam even though they're
ordered and on webcam famine right now
because of the lockdowns
but find a way use your phone use your
laptop webcam and start creating content
we started a weekly q a show and now
i've been able to connect with so many
people
because it was a response to what's
happening in the world right now
you gotta pivot your plan man you gotta
you gotta pivot what
other option do you have i know you're
scared go live today
i know you're scared shoot that video
edit it upload it
i know you're nervous press record
you gotta punch fear in the face you
gotta press report record
poop your pants scared facts
you gotta press record armpits sweaty
knees weak mom spaghetti there's vomit
on his sweater
already mom spaghetti anybody know that
reference shout out in the comments if
you know that reference
okay we should land the plane uh hey i
appreciate you so much smash the like
button if you got a value out of today
see you next week on all the the various
shows
and uh if you want some more content go
check out uh
the uh think marketing podcast and i
will see you
in the next video peace